breaking news to start with today
yesterday could have been maybe the
biggest day in the Trump Russia
investigation so far and not so much
because of what did happen but almost
because of what didn't happen in terms
of the requests from Robert Muller for
jail time for former national security
adviser Michael Flynn
so yesterday I mentioned just to catch
you up that we were awaiting the
sentencing for Michael Flynn Michael
Cohen and Paul Manafort three of the
really biggest indicted players so far
in the Trump Russia investigation
national security advisor personal
lawyer and campaign chairman
respectively
Robert Muller is recommending little to
no jail time for Michael Flynn because
he has been so extraordinarily useful to
the investigation and we learned from
the court filings around sentencing
yesterday that Michael Flynn did 19
interviews with Robert Muller's team
gave them documents gave them
communications he may even have been
responsible for convincing other people
to cooperate with the investigation and
the memo from Robert Muller about Flynn
sentencing is so heavily redacted as
we're showing to our television and
video audience in terms of the details
of what Flynn provided that we don't
really know exactly what he provided you
can barely see anything on these pages
other than the fact that Flynn has
really really cooperated here so the
maximum possible sentence for Flynn
based on what he pled to was five years
in prison and his agreement with Muller
has led to a sentencing memo from Muller
allowing for or recommending would be
better said zero to six months prison
time so this can be interpreted a couple
of different ways the interpretation
most favorable to Donald Trump would be
listen this is great news for Trump
because Flynn clearly did so little
wrong he committed so little criminal
allottee that not much prison time is
being recommended that's not a hugely
believable explanation because Muller
agreed to a plea deal where Flynn only
had to plead guilty to one count of
lying to federal agents and agreed to
write the sentencing memo recommending
zero to six months because Flynn
cooperated so fully they wouldn't make
such a deal with someone who had nothing
to tell if that makes sense
so then we get to the next
interpretation which is that the
National Security Advisor Michael Flynn
was so useful to Robert Muller in
providing evidence about even bigger
fresh fish that he essentially
cooperated his way to pleading guilty to
one count with a recommendation for zero
to six months jail time meaning that
what Flynn provided is potentially going
to bring down even bigger players in
this entire thing and if you look at the
wording of the memo that Robert Muller
wrote which we're talking about it
references how Michael Flynn had long
term first-hand experience about what
took place and who did it and when that
gets us beyond circumstantial evidence
in hearsay which is what the Wright has
been using to defend Donald Trump and
his cronies Flynn specifically knew what
was going on he was a witness to what
was going on so simply understand it in
this way if the National Security
Adviser is getting off with no or almost
no jail time what have the people higher
on the totem pole done and I want to
remind you of something else along those
lines this is just one of three criminal
investigations in which Flynn has
participated there are two other
investigations taking place here Trump
clearly panicked tweeting about
everything other than this over the last
12 to 14 hours 10 tweets about tariffs
and China not a single tweet about Flynn
and this is also really important Pat
because we've seen Trump sort of playing
coy trying to influence the testimony of
Paul Manafort and of Roger stone by
talking about how good people are strong
and they don't talk to Muller Pat
Lyne proves that if you just tell the
truth and cooperate you don't need to
rely on possible pardons from trump at
some point in the future just telling
the truth made it so that michael Flynn
doesn't need a pardon from Trump yeah
and it sounds like that has worked it's
been a successful flip and we talked
about you know Michael Flynn turning on
people who are higher than him on the
totem pole they really aren't that many
names there I mean Michael Flynn he gave
that that big speech at the Republican
National Convention he was a foreign
policy adviser I think on the campaign
trail and then became Trump's national
security advisors we all know like who
ranks higher than that maybe people in
Trump's family like Don jr. and Kushner
but the president's really the only
person I can think of yet there's not
that much between Flynn and Trump there
was only some players there meanwhile
Fox News is pretending that this isn't
happening Hannity had like a very brief
segment yesterday where he had a
Republican on to claim oh this is all
great news because this sentencing memo
doesn't even say anything about
collusion with Russia which may be the
most infantile and dumb comment I can
imagine about all of this particularly
when that memo is almost completely
redacted but more importantly because
that just means the investigations still
going on and Robert Mulder's not Robert
Muller has effectively had no leaks the
leaks we've seen have come from other
sources sometimes they're true sometimes
they're not sometimes they've just been
made up so that that is arguably the
dumbest take on this but if that's what
they want to tell themselves they're
gonna find themselves extraordinarily
taken aback over the next four to six
months as more indictments and charges
come forward